People need the symbol they need a
cap
that little girl kicked your ass
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my video for the other new falcon and winter
soldier trailer that's right marvel actually
released two different falcon and winter
soldier trailers with some different footage
so we'll explain what's going on with that
and some of the other new confirmed characters
like the new patriot character another new young
avengers character they're introducing during
the series don cheadle also confirmed that he
would guest star on falcon and winter soldiers
so war machine will show up and they'll help set
up some of the other disney plus series that are
coming in the future like the armor wars series
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes they're going to be starting next month
in march so be sure to subscribe to get all those
we're also doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your predictions
for the series on the video but just starting
with the alternate footage in the new version of
the trailer it starts with a different scene of
falcon inside the captain america section of the
smithsonian looking at the new display with the
classic world war ii captain america costume
in his shield remember we visited this museum
several times in the mcu there was some alternate
footage with him also in the museum just looking
at all the captain america fanfare obviously
this is all just to connect to that scene at
the end of avengers end game when he gave him the
shield old man captain america basically told him
you become the next captain america but if the
shield is now in the display in the smithsonian
now it means at some point after this moment in
avengers end game thunderbolt ross or maybe the
government takes the shield back or falcon gives
it back to them like you have that dialogue of
winter soldiers saying people need the symbol
they need a version of captain america to help
give them something to rally around to believe
in the way they're presenting this footage
they're implying that falcon may have initially
been reluctant to take up the title right away
classic trope reluctant hero and that sets off the
battle for the shield between all these competing
versions of captain america from the comics
like the batman battle for the cow aspect of
the story there's like four or five different
running story lines during the series it's the
same thing as Wandavision like even though it's
mostly a house of m story during Wandavision all
about her giving birth to these children them not
being real and then completely losing her mind
there's a lot of other stories going on in stuff
that they're setting up during those episodes
but later in the falcon and winter soldier trailer
there are a ton of separate scenes where he does
have the shield like where you see winter soldier
teaching him how to use it how to throw it so that
it returns like a frisbee hat tipped to ultron
for one of my favorite avengers jokes he was
clowning on humanity because vibranium has so many
properties you can use it for almost anything it's
so advanced but the humans as he says used it to
create a frisbee this scene to them on the boat
where winter soldier is telling him the importance
of having a captain america this briefcase that
falcon is opening is probably the shield itself
because the scenes of them training with it seem
like they're happening at the same location this
scene is also a nice callback to the captain
america winter soldier movie where you have bucky
catching the shield with his metal arm just like
he did during the movie and is also a reference to
him at one point in the comics being a version of
captain america i know people were disappointed
we didn't see more footage of us agent captain
america during the trailer this scene of them that
they keep showing in all the separate footage at
the football game this ceremony is probably just
the military trotting him out like everybody
celebrate we've just minted a new captain america
so if he's got the shield for a good portion of
the series it sounds like thunderbolt ross at some
point of the government just take the shield back
i know people are wondering if there are multiple
different shields during the trailer just because
it shows up all over the place but i believe it's
meant to be the same shield it's not like the
government just suddenly found a whole bunch of
vibranium or stole a whole bunch more from wakanda
that'd be like a whole other subplot stealing
vibranium from wakanda that sounds familiar
can't imagine that they'd be too happy about that
but this is what u.s agent looks like without his
costume on like this kind of looks like it's a
scene of a before and after like before he gets
the super soldier serum and then after thunderbolt
ross gives him a couple doses i talked about it
in my last trailer video but a big subplot of
the series is someone probably thunderbolt ross
resurrecting the super soldier serum program
the way they explain it on the series though
is that he's basically thunderbolt ross's in the
military's next experiment after the abomination
went sideways and the way that the mcu has put
it so far is that thunderbolt ross was the one
who was personally responsible for resurrecting
the super soldier program a long time ago and
then evolving it into the mcu version of the
weapons plus program the difference between the
weapons plus program is that each new iteration
of the program they have a new test subject and
they try different experiments to turn them into
different types of super soldiers with each new
iteration they try different treatments different
versions of super soldier treatments eventually
they also start experimenting on mutants that's
where you get to things like weapon x weapon 10
the wolverine version of the program deadpool is
also technically weapon 11 although that doesn't
confirm that thunderbolt ross will be the one to
create mcu wolverine i'll explain that in a second
too for the most part though in the mcu it's been
thunderbolt ross behind all of the versions of the
weapons plus program kevin feige said that they
haven't come close to casting the new version of
wolverine yet so in present day right now after
avengers end game at least during the course
of falcon and winter soldier i don't know which
iteration of the weapons plus that they'll be on
like which number u.s agent is going to be but
just for reference captain america is listed as
designation weapon one because he was supposed
to be the first even though the isaiah bradley
version of captain america is a bit of an easter
egg that they'll talk about during the series then
nuke from the marvel netflix shows if you remember
him jessica jones he was technically weapon seven
even though they kind of did something different
with him during the marvel netflix series then the
way they explain it is that in the comics after
they get to wolverine in the weapon x program
after he escapes the team behind weapon 10 striker
they became a rival team for the mainstream
weapons plus program so deadpool came from the
rival faction even though he's weapon 11 they were
like the canadian version of the program because
deadpool is canadian just like ryan reynolds
kevin feige is usually pretty good at juggling
all these really complicated easter eggs and
making it feel really simple and easy to follow
so i'll just talk about that when we start getting
those easter eggs during the [ __ ] winter soldier
episodes but if you haven't watched it in a while
it would be helpful to go back and re-watch the
incredible hulk movie because that's where you
get all your weapons plus easter eggs and the emil
blonsky version of the abomination who is coming
back during the she-hulk series maybe we'll see
some easter eggs for him during falcon and winter
soldier as well because of all the thunderbolt
stuff that they're setting up there were also a
lot of you in my last falcon and winter soldier
video that were asking about the scrolls easter
eggs that you thought you saw during the trailer
footage this is the scene that everyone was
talking about where it seems like baron zemo
in the background here off of frame is doing
something to make winter soldier fight all of his
henchmen and these villains and what i'm assuming
is madra poor mad rapport is a big location in the
series and it's just a big port of call for marvel
villains it's just a really shady place from the
x-men comics but while this big down and dirty
fight is happening you notice in the background
here you see all these skulls adorning the wall in
formation like their trophies of some kind they do
look like they could be skulls of scrolls because
of their shape like they're obviously not human
skulls but i've never seen the skeleton of an mcu
scroll so it's a little hard to tell without
more context about what's happening here but
it would make sense that the scrolls have been on
earth for a while now and people would be hunting
them for all kinds of reasons both villains
going after them and then regular superheroes
so there might be some scrolls easter eggs during
the series just in service of helping late track
work to set up the secret invasion nick fury
series that's releasing next year sometime
i'm also expecting monica rambo to come back at
least for a little bit during that cameo just
because she's so connected to sword nick fury the
space station and it's going to be a big nick fury
series there are a lot of you that are also asking
what's going on with war machine roadie during the
course of the series because don cheadle confirmed
that war machine would show up during falcon and
winter soldier episodes so i'm assuming that that
means that they'll also help use him to set up the
armor war series that we'll also be releasing
sometime next year the really cool connection
between war machine and monica rambo though is
that they're obviously both from the air force
but if you look at some of the easter eggs there
are some that point to them being pretty close
to the same age pre-snap there's some information
that quotes him as being born in the late 60s so
he's about the same age as iron man which would
put him in his mid 50s after avengers end game
but there's also some easter eggs from captain
america civil war that claim he was in his mid
30s during that movie too so it is possible that
monica rambo knows or has worked with war machine
in the past they both came up through the air
force so they'd have that connection as well
but based on all the Wandavision episodes so
far they've explained that before the events of
the snap and avengers infinity war monica rambo
had already been part of sword for a good long
while like she was basically raised there when
she wasn't at school or going through the air
force academy and as you've seen there's a lot of
classified files information that they deal with
so they have a lot of the information about the
avengers and their adventures the big battles
they've had through the first avengers movie
all the way through avengers age of ultron
because they know all about the vision then
avengers infinity war and now avengers end
game so she has pretty much all the information
she would need to know exactly what's going on
with war machine the other avengers characters
but i don't know if monica rambo and roadie are
going to share any scenes anytime soon before she
comes back potentially during the secret invasion
nick fury series in the captain marvel 2 movie
it's possible that also in service of setting up
the armor war series they bring back the justin
hammer character or they reference him at some
point during falcon and winter soldier the whole
thing with young avengers in the patriot character
if you're not familiar with him his name is
elijah bradley he's going to debut during the
series i don't know exactly how they're going
to use him during that but he's the grandson
of isaiah bradley that i talked about in my last
video the og african-american version of captain
america so you can see some of the connections
behind the scenes but i think it's going to be
a long time before we see any potential young
avengers series because you have characters like
miss marvel that aren't going to debut until later
this year then you have haley steinfeld's kate
bishop character that's going to debut during the
hawkeye series and we're not going to see the new
version of cassie lang the stature version played
by catherine newton they've recast the character
she won't show up till ant-man 3 and that movie
isn't going to happen until 2022. in lately on
Wandavision we've just seen billy and tommy wicken
and speed other og young avengers characters show
up so obviously in service of setting that team up
eventually kevin feige's using the marvel disney
plus series to set up all these characters and
bring them together the same way he did during the
marvel phase 1 movies like they all debut in their
different series then eventually somebody puts a
new team together but i don't know if it would
be nick fury to put that team together because
he's put all the other avengers teams together
or if it'd be somebody like monica rambo so it's
probably going to be 2023 before we see any real
actual young avengers team come together but i'll
just continue to point out easter eggs for that as
we go along the fun thing about the marvel disney
plus series so far like the Wandavision episodes
is they've been easter eggs for way more future
stuff than we ever expected like we've already
started seeing some fantastic four easter eggs
but i guess we shouldn't be surprised by that but
what'll happen is because we're so close to falcon
and winter soldier episodes starting we're going
to see more trailers in the next couple of weeks
towards the Wandavision finale but Wandavision
will basically run to the beginning of march
my full Wandavision episode six video will post on
friday just like normal i have another quicksilver
bonus video that i'm working on right now that
should post tomorrow if you spotted any other
big easter eggs during the trailer footage that i
didn't talk about during the video just write them
below in the comments but everyone click here for
that other really big falcon and winter soldier
trailer with the different footage and click here
for that brand new Wandavision episode 6 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!